[Applause]
[Music]
if you don't know this Dolph and I have
been very close friends for many many
years and I think it's safe to say that
you're a ladies man but you're
perpetually single
honestly Dolph has lost more girls than
a nice Detention Center in El Paso good
star yes sara is a country music singing
truck driving beer drinking redneck way
the only thing feminine about her is
she's not funny
[Laughter]
I'm gonna just prove your point about
two seconds
[Applause]
you know the first time I went over to
dolf's house there was pink underwear
everywhere and I was like did you have a
bunch of girls over last night but of
course they were his underwear and I was
like wow there's more pink in this house
than the Susan G Komen Foundation and
the same number of breasts all that
build-up I don't know if you prove me
wrong but still
Sarah is a down-home southern girl she's
a tomboy her friends used to love to
throw the pigskin around and when they
were done Sarah they'd all go
play football
[Applause]
speaking of breaks tops last girlfriend
broke up with him and I don't blame her
because every time he went down on her
he would tap out after a three-count
[Applause]
Sarah if we weren't such good friends I
would feel like that you were a little
jealous that I'm a wrestler you know
every week you have to watch me your
friend walk down the aisle while music
plays and everyone's looking at me and
there's a ring at the end to be fair to
be fair I get pinned by big sweaty guys
but I get paid millions of dollars when
you do it it's just for like Waffle
House and a ride home
[Applause]
I was worried about dog because he's had
three concussions so I'm always worried
that he's gonna have CTE but I know
you're never gonna kill yourself because
if there's one thing you don't have in
your house it's a belt
[Applause]
this might be the CTE and the
concussions talking but you look pretty
tonight Sarah Sarah I didn't know how
intense this was gonna get I didn't know
if I'd have to bust out a superkick but
I mean I know when you're act you say a
lot you know you're you're not married
you're getting down the line and just I
didn't want that to be the only time you
ever felt a kick in your stomach
[Applause]